bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 4 février tout
de suite les titres de l'actualité
locale
c'est la semaine de l'apprentissage dans
l'artisanat la troisième édition de ce
rendez vous se déroule jusqu'au 6
février l'occasion de découvrir les
formations proposées par les cfa de la
région ile de france nous en parlons
avec notre invité
renan keraudren président de la chambre
des métiers de l'artisanat des yvelines
des femmes taxi au secours des victimes
de violences conjugales le principe des
bons taxi le dispositif présent à
l'échelle nationale a été à déployer
pour la première fois dans le
département à l'origine l'association
iris
une convention a été signée en ce sens à
la mairie tél et puis rencontre avec la
team vanille à la fin de cette édition
ces bénévoles confectionnent des
pâtisseries remises régulièrement aux
soignants forces de l'ordre du
territoire leur façon de les remercier
pour leur engagement dans la crise
sanitaire du colis de 19 et jean castex
qui vient de prendre la parole le
premier ministre doit faire des annonces
en lien avec la crise sanitaire
quasiment trois semaines après la mise
en place du couvre feu à 18h sur
l'ensemble du territoire nous
surveillions bien sûr ces annonces sur
lesquels nous reviendrons à la fin de
cette édition
sa mission lui a été confiée justement
par le premier ministre jean noël barrot
et en sortie est en sortie est en
mission sortie de crise et rebond
économique dans le territoire c'est dans
ce cadre qu'il est venu cette semaine à
saint quentin en yvelines rencontrer les
élus et plusieurs acteurs industriels
comme le groupe renault et airbus
s'était hier mercredi au ski cuba
guyancourt au programme des échanges sur
le bilan de l'année 2020 et la situation
économique sur le territoire et coûté
ses réactions à la fin de cette
rencontre collectées par nicolas landry
français le 50 années d
généralement c'est qu'effectivement
coexistent des industries qui sont très
très durement éprouvée aéronautique
automobile et des industries qui vont
d'une certaine manière bénéficier de d2
l'accélération produite par la crise je
pense en particulier au numérique et à
la cybersécurité la question c'est
comment est ce qu'on fait dialoguer ces
acteurs-là faire en sorte que d'une
certaine manière la la faiblesse des uns
puissent faire la force des autres et
qu'on puisse unir nos forces sur ce
territoire là pour accompagner les
compétences les salariés des uns vers
les autres et faciliter le rebond global
du territoire
on est des entreprises qui vont bien
qu'ils sont très peu touché on a une ou
deux tiers qui qui va passer entre les
gouttes mais voilà qui souffrent et puis
un autre tir qui vraiment est en
difficulté et on a demandé d'abord que
il est plus une intervention de la
proximité on est nous vraiment le
développement économique de proximité
plus bien entendu éventuellement d'avoir
un fond qu'on nous accorde un fond voilà
qui nous on peut soutenir encore plus
directement plus vite nos entreprises
jusqu'au 5 février c'est la semaine de
l'apprentissage dans l'artisanat
l'occasion de parler de cette thématique
avec mon invité c'est ronan qui rôdent
rennes bonsoir bonsoir président de la
chambre de métiers de l'artisanat des
yvelines alors l'adage dit que
l'artisanat c'est la première entreprise
de france
est ce que le secteur se porte bien
malgré la crise sanitaire
le mot est juste eu mal gré mais d'une
façon générale on peut dire que
effectivement l'artisanat se porte bien
aujourd'hui nos chantiers henri p suite
au premier chantier fermé et d'une façon
générale le carnet de commandes se passe
bien je peux vous donner comme exemple
des bouchers qui n'en finissent pas de
fournir des boulangers dont je recherche
en embauche donc il ya du bon donc ça se
vérifie aussi dans les yvelines
comme en général aussi refait moi-même
capa personnel particulier j'embauche
gêneront pas mais ça sonne au débat on
imagine toute l'importance du coût de
cette semaine c'est de mettre en lumière
ce set
cet artisanat en france est l'alpha
tissage c'est surtout d'apprentissage
que l'on veut mettre en valeur puisque
les parents toujours tendance à dire
passe ton bac d'abord mais il faut
savoir que l'apprentissage c'est 250
métiers
grosso modo ici sur le
sur le site de versailles nous avons des
bouchers boulangers et pâtissiers
coiffeurs esthétique donc ça tourne de
ce côté là l'apprentissage c'est pour
cette année on a 12 % de plus de hausse
de d'apprentis inscrits par rapport à
l'année dernière donc ça se porte très
bien
les gens se rencontrent avec un
apprentissage on arrive à être les
patrons de demain même si c'est là la
transition se fait pas de suite
naturellement est ce que les entreprises
malgré encore cette crise sanitaire est
ce qu'elles sont réfractaires à prendre
des apprentis aujourd'hui ou pas du tout
alors c'est pas le terme réfractaires en
soit c'est qu'on est un petit peu dans
le doute et certains nous avons une
quarantaine de jeunes aujourd'hui qui
sont prêts à venir chez nous qui ont
signé un contrat mais on n'a pas de
maître d'apprentissage en voir en face à
m parce que certains se sentent pas très
très bien les marches au moins bonne de
passer du temps à former c'est pas
toujours facile donc on a une
quarantaine de jeunes alors on a une
passerelle pour cela pendant six mois on
peut les garder au cfa mais on attend et
on cherche on les aide avec des
développeurs de chez nous pour trouver
le maître d'apprentissage qui va bien
d'ailleurs depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire plusieurs annonces du
gouvernement les derniers on y reviendra
à la fin de ce journal il ya eu le plan
de relance aussi de l'étain qui a été a
annoncées qui permet aux entreprises de
percevoir une aide supplémentaire pour
l'embauché d'apprentis tout à fait alors
une aide de 5000 euros pour les mineurs
8000 euros pour les nageurs mais comme
je peux le dire aussi on n'est pas là
pour gagner l'argent sur le dos des
appentis c'est sûr que c'est de la
trésorerie toujours tendue mais on est
là pour
faire passer le savoir et donc l'argent
c'est secondaire entre guillemets quels
sont les avantages de l'apprentissage
écouter marie avec christelle cochet de
l'association nationale de la formation
automobile qui gère et guyancourt le
campus des services de l'automobile et
de la mobilité
l'apprentissage c'est un tremplin vers
l'emploi
la farce de l'apprentissage c'est de
pouvoir avoir une période d'alternance
entre l'école et l'entreprise ce qui
permet aux jeunes d'avoir une réelle
expérience de terrain de se confronter
aux réalités du métier et de renforcer
leurs compétences et leurs connaissances
tant à l'école que dans leurs
entreprises
un jeune qui intègre aujourd'hui cette
filière de l'artisanat est ce qu il a de
belles perspectives d'avenir tout à fait
il va commencer par le plus bas de
l'échelle
effectivement mais on a aussi des
apprentis qui sont en bts donc à portée
de là c'est pas forcément le niveau le
plus bas et il va monter il va évoluer
il va devenir un chef d'equipe et à la
fin comme je vous dis ça sera le patron
de demain pour que le chiffre c'est 80 %
d'apprentis qui trouvent un emploi
pérenne en sortie de c'est tout à fait
ça on a 90 % de réussite
aux examens et en a 80 % qui sont
embauchés dès la sortie désagréable sur
le territoire des yvelines l'offre de
formation elle est varié avec comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure nous dans
notre centre de cfa on a si cette
formation qui tourne
on est presque complet donc c'est pour
vous dire que ça marche bien et je
disais qu en cours il ya le campus des
services de l'automobile et de la
mobilité qui organisait d'ailleurs ses
portes ouvertes la semaine dernière
présentation des formations à qui ils
sont dispensés au micro de mélanie
poquet le campus des services de
l'automobile et de la mobilité de
guyancourt répond à une forte demande
des entreprises sur le secteur pour
former des apprentis aux métiers de la
voiture de la moto et du vélo il est
possible de rentrer en formation dès le
cp jusqu'au bac + 4 sur le campus grâce
aux différents organismes qui sont
présents on dénombre ainsi cinq
établissements qui sont liées cm là fort
pas le gars ac lampert et le gnf à qui
propose un accès aux différents métiers
de la maintenance des services de la
réparation et du commerce
donc on le votera vers aussi de cet
exemple renault keraudren que ronan qui
redonne pardon que c'est une voie large
l'artisanat il ya plus de 250 métiers
possibles dans ce secteur alors pas que
dans les yvelines comme mac os x trem
effectivement chez 200 chacun des
métiers qui sont là dans l'artisanat
avec des exemples variés
là on va parler de des métiers de
l'automobile l'automobile des fleuristes
des restaurateurs il ya de tout du
bâtiment effectivement et jusque des
tout petits des déserts loger tout est
là et à guyancourt également resta a dû
employer le lycée hôtelier qui propose
plusieurs parcours dont les ces apps et
pâtisseries parmi les élèves de la
section est divia aguerris et l'élan
pour toi ce partage son temps entre un
pâtissier traiteur à versailles est
également l'école c'est notre interview
express au micro de michael aime idron
je suis sortie du collège j'ai débuté
avec un crp cuisine en deux ans je lui
eus et j'ai suivi par un c ap pâtisserie
six mois on a neuf mois j'ai choisi ce
métier car ça me passionne depuis tout
petit et je voulais découvrir à fêter
quoi travers de la pâtisserie carton new
deal avril à partir et efface été facile
mais c'est pas facile du tout quand on
arrive et on découvre c'est quoi ça
enchaîne les chloride avait satisfait ça
vient beaucoup de travail je suis deux
semaines à l'école décès mais
l'entreprise on apprend plus son
apprentissage que au lycée nous montre
les bases comment ça fonctionne comme on
coupe
comment on fait les glaçage s'appuie un
autre prise il ya plus de choses à faire
il ya plus de variété que à l'école ici
par exemple ils vont nous dire de faire
une quiche la brioche alors que là bas
c'est que le temps des nouveautés ça
s'enchaîne seront c'est une étape sur
dix en fait ici c'est un sur cinq vit là
bas c'est un sur dix il ya plus des
choses je crois qu'on en plus on gagne
de l'argent en étant jeune
donc on a déjà une étape ivan
[Musique]
là je fais finir mon année après j'ai
poursuivre avec un ace et un petit three
chocolaterie glacis mon objectif à moi
ils devraient ma propre boîte
la pâtisserie traditionnelle tous qui
échoue avec la crème puisque les pâte à
choux avec de la fin que ça existait
plus en ce moment il faudrait reprendre
tout ce qui était de l'ancienneté et
remettre des mauvais pour un nouveauté
donc on l'a vu dans les interviews à
plusieurs voies d'accès différents
diplômes qui permettent d'accéder aux
différents métiers
donc cette semaine on l'a dit c'est
l'occasion de parler de l'artisanat de
l'apprentissage ça va se poursuivre à
des portes ouvertes en virtuel c'est ça
pour s'adapter aux 6,1 malgré tout à se
tasser frontex et donc on a une journée
portes ouvertes ce samedi en virtuel
toujours sur le même site toute la
semaine nous avons passé des tutos aussi
bien de la presse africaine que
soeur de la boucherie la boulangerie il
ya même des une recette de galette j'ai
cru voir enfin 16 ans tous les jours au
dojo vous aurez de plus tôt possible et
on aura une deuxième journée portes
ouvertes alors en espèrant présentiel le
20 mars
voilà en visite de notre centre donc
avec toutes les informations à retrouver
sur le lien qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran un dernier mot pour terminer
vous parlais tout à l'heure de la
présence à versailles
là on en discutait tout à l'heure en or
il y avoir une présence aussi sur le
nord des villes le notre souci c'est que
nous sommes plein comme un oeuf sont
le centre est plein et on est en
pourparlers avec le président bédié du
conseil départemental pour monter un
centre de formation sur nantes où on
pourrait délocaliser une partie et nous
étendre pour faire aussi de la formation
pour les gens qui veulent se reconvertir
ça c'est possible aussi et mètres de là
la formation en formation continue
merci renaud qui redonne est devenu en
plateau pour parler de l'apprentissage
et de l'artisanat je rappelle que vous
êtes le président de la chambre des
métiers et de l'artisanat des yvelines
merci d'avoir été avec nous merci lors
du 2ème confinement les violences
conjugales ont augmenté de 60 %
confirmant ainsi à la tendance observée
lors du premier confinement pour lutter
à agir vite contre ce phénomène le
premier dispositif dans les yvelines des
bons taxi a été lancé cinq femmes taxis
peuvent être mobilisés à tout moment
pour aller chercher les femmes victimes
de violences et les mettre à l'abri
une convention a été signée tout
récemment aux mairies de ben avec trois
de ses conductrice et l'association iris
qui pilote le dossier sur le territoire
c'était en présence du maire de la
commune qui soutient l'association de la
déléguée départementale aux droits des
femmes et de la gendarmerie pour une
réponse plus coordonnée face aux
violences faites aux femmes mais bon
taxi à l'iris l'état le département et
le groupement de gendarmerie des
yvelines qui forment d'ailleurs les
chauffeurs et depuis 2020 les bons taxis
ont été appelés à cinq reprises dans les
yvelines écouter ses interviews j'ai
déjà transportent les personnes ya
quelques années
mise à l'abri en fait de percer dans
deux femmes battues avec enfants et donc
j'ai
quand on m'a proposé de faire partie du
groupe taxi j'ai dit oui la cause mais
tient particulièrement à coeur
qu'est ce qui est en jeu une femme donc
je vois que voilà malheureusement avec
l'actualité et une hausse quand même
assez importante des violences
conjugales donc je trouvais ça important
de pouvoir aider les personnes qui ont
besoin justement de pouvoir être enfin
de pouvoir se déplacer est mobile et de
parler d accompagner donc c'est quelque
chose qui est très important pour moi ta
question de la mobilité à les centrales
c'est comment un moment pouvoir se
mettre à l'abri ou comment aller sur des
démarches administratives
quand finalement vous n'êtes ni véhicule
et si vous n'avez pas de tiers de
confiance qui peut vous emmener dans un
lieu sécurisé en effet en fait aller
elle et pour nous en tout cas prégnante
sur les territoires ruraux il donc les
bons taxi avec l'association iris qui a
répondu favorablement
j'ai toujours trouvé qu'en fait ce bond
taksim manquer en tout cas au maillage
territorial
mais la signature de la convention a été
aussi l'occasion de remettre des sièges
auto bébé pour les conductrices les
conductrice de taxi afin de pouvoir
transporter également les enfants de ces
femmes victimes de violences et si vous
vous donniez de votre temps par exemple
une heure par mois votre voisin la ville
de saint cyr l'école s'est jointe à
l'association voisins solidaires pour
mettre en place une action de solidarité
seller civique
les explications de sonia broc maire de
la commune recueillis par mélanie poker
[Musique]
j'ai passé un quart par semaine j'ai au
moins une heure tard par mois à donner
est en effet 7 heures comme ça
positionné n'importe où et compliqué à
valoriser et l'objectif pour nous c'est
vraiment en fait de récupérer toute
cette ressource et de la mettre à
disposition des associations qui en ont
le plus besoin c'est un peu une
plateforme un lieu où les personnes
peuvent donner leur temps qu'on sera
tous capables de prendre notre petit
doigt zine de l'ami au centre de
vaccination parce qu'elle n'a pas de
moyen de locomotion
je reste convaincu que ben voilà donner
un petit coup de main les joue au
scrabble pendant une heure avec pas
forcément une personne seniors mais
peut-être tout simplement quelqu'un qui
a plus de difficultés à avoir du lien
social le plus vite possible
toujours mais honnêtement je pense que
on devrait être prêt d'ici fin février à
peu près cette semaine la rédaction de
tv 78 de vous présenter des jeunes issus
des quartiers qui est continue
aujourd'hui à s'y investir tout juste
titulariser cédric jbeli est animateur
au centre de loisirs de coignières il
veut aider les jeunes de sa commune son
portrait par célia 200 go avec un
diplôme de cuisinier en poche cédric
jbeli n'était pas prédestiné à
l'animation en 2014
ils découvrent le métier d'animateur de
centre de loisirs un secteur qui lui a
plu tout de suite je
l'ambiance voilà voir le parcours des
enfants les aider à avancer je trouve ça
bien de voir les voir grandir on la
rapporte quelque chose et ça c'est très
important
titularisé en octobre cédric jumelles y
travaille avec les maternelles ou les
élémentaires selon les besoins de la
structure
cet homme de 27 ans a grandi dans le
quartier des acacias à coignières j'ai
connu des personnes qui ont fait des
bêtises j'en ai fait moi même
mais voilà on grandit en faisant des
terreaux de choses donc c'était une
opportunité que la ville m'a donné
travail et que les jeunes d'ici j'ai
apprécié aujourd'hui j'ai deux les
jeunes justement pu faire ce genre de
bêtises en grandissant on se rend compte
que la vie c'est pas forcément de capter
des bêtises il est en bas du bâtiment
le directeur du centre qui le connaît
depuis l'enfance à penser directement à
lui pour intégrer son équipe
je le connais depuis de nombreuses
années c'est quelqu'un de sérieux c'est
quelqu'un qui aime rigoler il a toujours
eu un bon contact avec les les jeunes
delà de la ville donc je me suis dit
pourquoi pas essayer avec vraiment les
enfants
deux barrages qui l'a fait ben faut des
bills a commencé il a fait des
remplacements cantine centre de loisirs
en vacation donc là il est passé tirage
en titulaire cédric jbeli qui n'a vécu
quatre manières ne se voit pas autre
part toujours dans ma ville pour les
jeunes de ma vie c'est ce que j'aime
plus tard le coi n'y ait rien voudrait
travailler avec d'autres tranches d'âge
les adolescents voir les jeunes adultes
toujours dans l'idée d'aider les jeunes
et en raison de l'actualité nous n'avons
pas pu vous proposer cette semaine
l'ensemble de ces portraits dans le
journal ils seront à retrouver en ligne
dès demain dans l'émission à 7,8 dossier
sur tv 78 points comme eux sont investis
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
aux premières loges de l'épidémie les
soignants les services de secours mais
aussi des forces de l'ordre pour les
remercier une vingtaine de bénévoles
réunis au sein de la team vanille
pâtissent pour ces héros du quotidien
mélanie poquet les a rencontrés un
coffre plein de gourmandise florence et
joséphine livre les 84 pompiers de la
caserne de la celle-saint-cloud 400
produits sucrés et salés circule
beaucoup parce qu'on s'est rendu compte
depuis le début du co lead que les que
les gens étaient était était vraiment
très sympathique envers du coup les
forces de l'ordre et et on a en fait
reçu souvent quand c'est la première
fois qu'on a autant des diatomées ya
souvent des gens qui ne cuisinent qui
nous offre des pizzas des chocolats pour
nous soutenir et ça nous coûte beaucoup
florence et joséphine font partie de la
team vanille un groupe de vingt
bénévoles toutes des femmes et cuisine
pour celles et ceux qu'elle nomme les
roues du quotidien
au départ c'était pour les 5 ans et
maintenant on va faire également pour
les pompiers pour les orphelins
pour les et par le personnel d pad pour
les services médicaux des hôpitaux
une cuisine qui se fait chaque dimanche
masqué et ganté des recettes simples ou
plus élaboré ce jour là je vous ai fait
une prépa requis chocolat spéculoos et
fondant au chocolat
on sait toujours que le chocolat y est
quand même un élément qui nous assure un
peu de succès ça c'est sûr
on essaye de trouver des produits frais
aussi les produits bio donc on fait des
souffles moi je fais des soupes aussi
surtout en ce moment pour avoir quand
même une petite partie salée et puis le
samedi on essaye sur notre petit groupe
ou à de simples la team là de dire un
petit peu ce qu'on a prévu de faire pour
éviter que les 400 cookies au chocolat
par exemple les pâtissières ont déjà
réalisé une trentaine de livraisons
depuis sa création en avril 2020 si des
passionnés de cuisine veulent participer
la team vanille les attend et avant de
refermer ce journal je vous le disais en
début d'édition le premier ministre jean
castex s'exprime ce soir vous le voyez
sur ces images
à propos de la crise sanitaire quasiment
en trois semaines après la mise en place
et du couvre-feu à 18h sur l'ensemble du
territoire français le premier ministre
a précisé lors de cette conférence de
presse que la situation du coronavirus
et du comité 19 resté particulièrement
fragile sur le sol français que l'on
était toujours dans un plateau de
circulation du virus est que la
progression des différents variant était
en augmentation on était à 3 % ou 8
janvier aujourd'hui à 14% à des cas de
coronavirus qui proviennent des variants
dans les yvelines les derniers chiffres
à vous donner sur les 24 heures les
dernières 24 heures +15 hospitalisations
plus cinq patients en réanimation et 6
décès supplémentaires en 24 heures
alors la conférence de presse les
dernières annonces que l'on peut vous
rappeler c'est que le premier ministre a
rappelé les dernières mesures
restrictives annoncé le 29 janvier
dernier notamment
je vous le rappelle la fermeture des
grands centres commerciaux ceux de plus
de 20 mille mètres carrés est les
restrictions supplémentaires également
aux frontières et le renforcement du
télétravail alors malgré le contexte
dont je viens de vous faire part pas de
nouveaux tours de vis de la part du
gouvernement
le
le ministre qui appelle tout de même les
français à une mobilisation générale
juste avant les vacances d'hiver le
confinement
elle n'est pour le moment pas pris pas
de confinement mais qui pourraient être
pris en dernier recours en cire les
chiffres venaient à aller qui ne
s'amélioreraient pas par la suite voilà
ce que l'on pouvait vous dire et on
reviendra sur les principales annonces
de jean castex demain lors de notre
édition du 7 8 week-end une émission qui
revient sur l'actualité qui vous
présente aussi à des idées de sorties
loisirs mais dont qui revient sur
l'actualité le sais tu ce week-end est
programmée demain s'est présentée par
eléonore sinoquet et célia gars tsongo
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité très belle soirée à
tous avec tv 78
[Musique]